[Music]
in this series you will realize the
changing landscape of organic social
media you'll be able to explain how paid
earned and owned media apply to social
you'll be able to recognize the
potential exposure social media can
offer for brands and you'll be able to
identify the three key areas of
converged media campaigns social media
has changed a lot of things about
marketing for a very long time it was
viewed as a segment of marketing that
was part of what you did like you might
do direct mail or you might do display
advertising these days social has
managed to bleed over so much into every
area of our lives in every area of how
we engage with consumers online but it
really is sort of redefined marketing as
a whole and that means that sometimes we
need to look beyond the things that we
view is social and look at the bigger
picture of marketing theory marketed
concepts and marketing approach to make
sure that we're not missing something
when it comes to social and it when it
comes to our overall digital marketing
strategy now sadly over the last few
years social has started to get harder
after years of almost a free ride on the
organic side brands are starting to see
a huge drop in organic exposure across
the board now I want to be crystal clear
that when I talk about a drop in organic
exposure I'm talking about a drop in the
exposure based on content brands are
publishing themselves I'm not talking
about the organic consumer driven
exposure that happens when someone comes
in and sees an article or a video they
like and chooses to share that with our
audience
now if we look at a site like Twitter
which really was sort of the place that
gave birth to the concept of massive
organic social exposure for links and
conversation that's sort of where it all
began
Twitter has finally joined the world of
social algorithm so that means that some
friends a little bit of the potential
for that free ride on Twitter is
starting to come to a screeching halt
because Twitter is now yet another
channel that judges your content and
makes the choice about whether or not it
will show up to your followers based on
those users and based on how they and
other individuals react to the content
that you actually publish out via your
feeds
now what an algorithm tends to mean in
the context of social and exposure the
idea is for great content to rise to the
top well week contents are sort of the
content glut that we have see happening
a lot these days kind of gets pushed
into the background with so much
conversation taking place among personal
connections and brands vying to get some
of that attention as well the idea
behind an algorithm is to really be able
to make a judgment call
on whether or not the content that your
brand is putting out and whether it's
good enough to force its way into the
feeds of the people that may at some
point in time have chosen to follow you
so when it comes to Twitter you guys do
a couple things on the organic side to
sort of understand what the groundwork
and the foundation looks like for you is
we move into this realm of converged
media concepts so if your target
audience is on Twitter take the time to
test a couple different things take a
look at trending hashtag usage and what
that tends to do to your conversations
does that get you more responses to get
your exposure to new people take a look
at strong social sharing powered by
users so making sure you've got that
quick and easy one-click sharing access
on your website on any of the content
that you have going out you've got some
type of motivating factor in there
that's important and checking to see how
much of the conversation that takes
place on Twitter comes from you and how
much comes from third party individuals
or consumers actually sharing your
content make sure that you're
encouraging followers to favorite tweets
to increase exposure much like the like
button on Facebook that's an area of the
Twitter algorithms
we've seen start to come into play so
whether or not someone retweets or even
responds to you if they click that
favorite button that sends a message to
Twitter about how they value the content
that you're putting out also make sure
that you're monitoring for customer
service needs based on post volume not
every company is going to need to have
24/7 around-the-clock coverage on
Twitter for some it's totally ok to only
be on there responding during business
hours it really depends on what the
volume of conversation is and what the
urgent immediacy of your customers might
be if and when they actually run into a
problem and then finally take advantage
of targeted advertising on Twitter to
test drive the idea of increased
exposure and engagement among different
target audiences or for different topics
and different ideas now when we move
into the realm of Facebook and we
consider sort of organic and B to what
that looks like for most businesses we
know that most companies tend to have a
little bit of a love-hate relationship
with Facebook there's a lot of potential
exposure there but there's also a lot of
changes that are constantly coming into
the algorithm most of which are designed
to make it a little bit harder for
businesses to get in front of people now
that said keep in mind that a facebook
fan is still 27% more likely than a non
Janne to make a purchase from a brand in
the months following some type of paid
campaign exposure on the site so whether
it's organic reach or whether it's paid
reach there's still a lot of opportunity
to drive some ultimate conversions
through this there's also the idea of a
facebook fans showing up as an
endorsement on a paid ad so the earned
of the paid coming into the mix together
here with a really high level of
influence on how non followers might do
the app because if someone is not
familiar with your brand sees people
that they know and trust
you've already engaged with the brand so
it's going to be a lot more likely to
get you some of that exposures from
curiosity and potentially a conversion
out of it so when we look at the realm
of sort of organic search and how it's
kind of pulling back over time it's
important to remember that social media
exposure doesn't matter any less today
than it did last year it's just about
learning how to adjust the approach
again to do that we need to go back to
some of those concepts that we use in
broader marketing terminology
to say how do we make sure all of our
areas of outreach and public relations
and own content and advertising and
targeting how they're all working
together to make sure we've got a
stronger message going out now that
social sharing is also critical to the
exposure you're looking for because 48%
of consumers view posts made by
connections it's a great way to discover
content trends brands and products
getting that exposure on social actually
getting in front of people it opens the
door to new opportunities with potential
clients and also to you gathering
stories and ideas from existing clients
that might factor into your marketing
down the road now it's important to
remember that content shared by
consumers is the best social exposure
you can get so enabling and encouraging
that social sharing by your audience is
a critical part of anything you're going
to do moving forward with social media
in fact we have an entire training
series on that idea of what drives their
social sharing that's definitely worth
getting in and taking a look at now if
we move outside of social and we go to a
more traditional approach to marketing
and outreach and exposure for ages
marketing and communications tended to
look at three different types of
exposure so we consider the concept of
paid of owned and have earned so the
question becomes in the context of
social what does it look like to have
those applied and actually put those to
work for you in the realm of social
media now when we look at the conflict
of paid media within social this is
where we're talking about things like
paid search ads sponsorships and
editorial placements promoted posts that
might show up on Facebook or Pinterest
or Instagram anything where you are
paying for the specific eyeballs
especially if there's an element of
targeting associated with it it's going
to count as paid media within social and
really within the broader digital
marketing place now there's also the
idea of owned me so the things that
count is owned media are going to be
your website your blog maybe the mobile
apps that you've created there's also
the concepts of partially owned media
now that we've moved into a realm of
social so that's going to be your
Facebook page your YouTube channel your
Pinterest feed so these are places where
you have full control over the content
but you don't have full and ultimate
control over everything about the
interaction and the space in which
people are engaging with you there's
also the idea of earned media within
social so these are things like
third-party reviews editorial mentions
social sharing these are the different
areas where consumers are saying here's
the experience that I've had with this
brand or this product I want to come out
and share it with people basically
telling their stories and you know
sharing their their own ideas of what
they think of your products or services
now traditionally marketing has tended
to think in budgets and especially when
we go into larger enterprise companies
we still kind of see a lot of division
among the owned earned and paid fund
so owned tends to be the breakdown of
things like content and the brand itself
what's going on the website what's going
into the blog what's the video that's
being produced for YouTube or for
Instagram whereas the urn is viewed more
as social sharing influence or outreach
and connections you know the things that
are designed to inspire that
conversation and that sort of i relized
spread within the digital landscape and
then we also have the idea of paid so
the advertising side of things and
whether that's PPC within the realm of
Google or whether that's highly targeted
promoted posts on something like Twitter
or Facebook or Pinterest anything that
you're going in and you're actually
running an active campaign on now for
the most part a lot of digital marketing
teams are still broken down into those
three columns you have your team that's
working on content they have your team
that's working on sort of PR and
outreach you have your team that's
working on the advertising side of
things and what tends to happen with
that is we also see that budgets tend to
get split up accordingly so the
allocation of funds is pretty standard
across the board usually your content
team had the least amount of money to
work with because most things were being
produced in-house or produced kind of
quickly and on a budget where's your
earn team might have a little bit more
to go from because they might be looking
at hosting events they
need a budget for product to get it out
in front of people or to bring
influencers in to have meetings or to
have engagement with them and then
finally advertising tended to have the
biggest bucket available because for a
lot of large companies advertising is
really the easiest way to guarantee that
you're getting exposure within the
social media or digital world now a new
approach to budgeting is really
important to give consideration to and
it's not always as simple as one bucket
just throwing everything in together but
the reality is that paid earned and
owned can no longer function is fully
independent funnels the can but the
results are not going to be as good as
they will be if you take the time to
have them work together so viewing your
budget is a broader digital marketing
strategy and looking at each of these
verticals is a portion of the team that
works together that's what we're going
to be exploring in this series is what
does it look like to have paid to
contribute to earned or earn contribute
to owned or any of the other combination
there else now to survive and social
you're going to need some ability to
adapt when you know how they work
together you can learn how to make them
more effective you can learn how to
trigger things like amplification or to
make use of say consumer generated
stories into your owned media or even
some of your paid advertising campaigns
that's the thing we're going to be
looking at in this series is what does
it look like to actually make these work
together hey once you become an expert
in digital marketing then subscribe to
the simply learned Channel and click
here to watch more such videos turner it
up and get certified in digital
marketing click here